good morning everybody we had a very
um sudden scheduling of a white house
press briefing with donald trump's press
secretary
kaylee mcenneny and we are
also watching live testimony from dr
anthony fauci
and dr robert redfield so there's a lot
going on today
and then donald trump with a full day of
propaganda ahead of him that may explain
why the press briefing was scheduled for
so early
um standing by about 15 minutes from uh
the start of that we're going to have
time to review some of the
um interesting moments from dr fauci's
testimony so far
um what else um i do want to look a
little bit at the latest polls we
haven't looked at polling lately and it
it actually is tightening a little bit
and as i said um
well i'm like it seems like i'm taller
in the morning i'm off the top of the
screen
that's weird my chair is at the normal
height but i'm somehow actually it could
just be that my hair is doing something
weird
um but in any case we are here
and um a lot of different and exciting
things going on
i do hope that we hear from kaylee
about plasma as well as rim disavar
two things that donald trump talked
about yesterday i was laughing
all night about plasma yesterday
and um my girlfriend's pretty annoyed by
it because i keep talking about plasma
and also saying p l o z m u h
p l o z m u h i actually
p-l-a-w-s-m-a is also funny i see some
people spelling it
that way um but but p
p-l-o-z-m-u-h for some reason just gets
me every single time
um and also yeah people recalling that
at first donald trump was calling it rum
reservoir like a reservoir of the spirit
the alcohol rum um but yesterday
rim disavar was was pretty wild
but there's nothing better than plasma
that's just absolutely the best
so one relevant moment from this uh
testimony from dr
let's just listen to a few seconds and
watch maybe the mask added we're working
on a vaccine
we sent a strong message to china this
will not be tolerated i'm glad the
administration took action by naming and
shaming those involved
as well as closing down a chinese
consulate that was a hub for
intellectual property
and trade secret theft we must hold
china accountable
okay so it sounds like it's actually
gone completely delusional so let let me
just play a clip for you that i think is
actually more relevant here was dr fauci
asked
why is the coronavirus so much worse in
the united states
and listen to what dr fauci said can you
help us understand why
why europe has largely contained the
virus
the united states has seen a continued
rise in new cases
thank you very much mr chairman the
answer that to that question is really
somewhat complex but i'll try maybe to
very briefly go through
this is much better than the rantings of
some republican lunatic but i believe
are at least some of the factors that
were involved
if you look at what happened in europe
when they shut down or locked down or
went to shelter in place
right however you want to describe it
they really did it to the tune of about
95
plus percent of the country did that oh
and so they didn't have like 45 percent
of the country that
thought bill gates was trying to
microchip them eventually okay
okay yeah you actually look at what we
did
even though we shut down even though it
created a great deal of difficulty
we really functionally shut down only
about 50 percent
in the sense of the totality of the
country which means when we reached our
peak
as they did they came down almost to a
low baseline as you've shown
very clearly but take a look at what
happened to our baseline we came up down
and then we plateaued at about 20 000
cases
a day so we started off with a very
difficult baseline
of transmission that was going on
so this is so important when we
remember that actually let's see if i
can even find it we had a point at which
this this is just so key we got up here
to about 35 000 cases a day
39 000 cases a day and then we got back
down here to about 20
000 right remember this was like early
june and
it was basically like hey we flatten the
curve it's time to let it rip
let's start opening back up when there
were 20 000 new cases a day
so of course then we got back up to as
many as 78 000 cases
we considered 20 that we not me lunatics
considered 20 000 cases a day to have
been fixing it and
as you can see that was within 10 days
you started seeing the seven day moving
average go up so it's like of course of
course this is not a surprise to anybody
anybody who understands realizes that
that makes absolutely no sense
oh the main event today is this suddenly
called and scheduled kaylee mcinanny
press briefing um at the bottom of the
hour
but we are keeping an eye on testimony
from doctors redfield and fouchy
as well um and dr redfield reminds me of
the quaker oats
guy i think for some reason i don't know
why um
i i i'm wondering is um
okay hold on a second
oh okay yeah do p so there's somebody in
twitch chat who is saying
is pacman a delusional libtard is that
something we should ban
people for like my instinct is no i
don't care if people
you know find my views reprehensible or
whatever i don't think that that's
bandworthy although there's people
calling for a ban
we basically banned for like you know
overt anti-semitism
uh you know n-word use um
pasting like uh asc to art
and like like you know uh
private arab you know genitals and in
asc to art and stuff like that
um so i i don't think we need to do that
yeah it's not bad people seem to agree
that it's not bandworthy yep we're not
going to ban for that so moderators
we can make that a policy criticisms of
me
don't don't trigger a ban that's
perfectly fine
obviously if it becomes anti-semitic or
it becomes
whatever anti-hispanic i take a lot of
the brunt of anti-hispanic claims
in ch i think at that point then we then
we go
uh okay some super chats are coming in
andrew bayhem says utah voting in
anti-trump governor purple state this
election polls are narrowing here in
some counties purple already
utah is not going to be the next place i
think to go blue
but um certainly certainly it's
it's not as red as it once was peasant
media says i told you three years ago
trump would suspend the election
matt chavez says will it hurt biden if
he doesn't pick a black woman
you know polls i looked at had black
voters preferring warren at one point so
no i don't i don't think so
neptune says thoughts on photos of
fouchy at the baseball game
um i mean listen uh you know sitting
with no one within a hundred feet
other than two people that he he you
know are kind of in his bubble and
pulling his mask down
does not seem like a big deal to me um i
i do the same when i'm you know biking
around and i'm just like
near my girlfriend we both take our
masks down you know i don't think it's a
big deal but then when people are near
us i put it back over my face
pear tiran says i think your moderators
are doing a good job excellent
that's good to hear let's take a look
just briefly let's see if anything has
gone live yet no let's take a look just
briefly at some of the latest polling
now if you believed that at one point
biden was winning by like 13 or 15
it appears as though the polls are
tightening a little bit new general
election poll from ibd
tipp has biden at plus seven
florida has biden at plus four he had
been as much as double digits in florida
pennsylvania though has biden plus nine
which is just
stunning biden plus 13 in new hampshire
is crazy
new hampshire is often close biden at
plus 11 in virginia
is completely out of this world
um yesterday we had a two days ago
general election poll had biden plus
nine
plus six and plus nine here are some
left-leaning polls
where biden is only up three in florida
uh that's that's relevant so i i think
if there's any takeaway for me it's
all the polls tell us is that there's a
clear opportunity to remove donald trump
and that's as far as we should go
anything that is in the direction of
biden's got this
is dangerous and i would advise very
very powerfully against that
um you know when we see polling that
says biden could be up seven or maybe up
three or maybe up one in florida what
that tells me is
if i'd live in florida i'm going to make
damn sure that i'm voting
because it could be a tie the margin if
the if it's plus two for biden with a
margin of error of three
that means trump could actually be
winning so it's an opportunity that's
all that it means and we should all make
sure that we understand that that's all
it means nobody should be thinking maybe
they don't need my vote maybe my vote's
not necessary
let me say thank you and welcome to
everybody watching on twitch
very very exciting announcement actually
let me see if i have any updates
um it looks as though
i will be co-streaming with chess
grandmaster hikaru nakamura
sometime in the next five days and it
could be
um it could be the event america's been
waiting for
to bridge the gap between left and right
okay so i will have a more specific
announcement
once i can make that but we are in very
very advanced discussions
um hikaru's representatives and my
representatives
we represent ourselves you understand
but his and my representatives are
talking right now
and we may be looking at a co-stream uh
in the next few days in advance of my
participation
in the pog champs ii um
tournament and i'm kidding about
bridging left and right i have no idea
what hikaru's politics are i think he
stays away from politics generally
but it's going to be very very powerful
and i think that's going to be soon
um i also am finalizing my next stream
with
um alexandra botez and
um eric rosen is going to be back in the
mix i'm really doing a full
full training for pog champs too but
that is not the subject today today the
subject is this
sudden press briefing scheduled with
kaylie mcananny
and we are also just kind of keeping an
eye
on testimony from dr robert redfield of
the cdc who is now going let's see his
mask
strategy oh i wanted to see whether he
went first over the ears
and uh because some people seem to not
even know how to put a mask on which is
weird
um okay uh over on twitch
logon pc has subscribed for three months
drew nielsen has subscribed
and spy hunter has subscribed which is
very very exciting
um we are targeting 50 000 followers
on twitch i want to also welcome the 7
600 of you watching
on youtube and just a fri extremely
friendly reminder
smash that like button and completely
disassemble
that subscribe button we are now at 906
almost 907 000 subscribers my goal
is a million by election day let's
actually get an
update from socialblade so when we
when we started oh there goes fauci's
mask um
technique is just flaw absolutely
flawless i've that that was
it was like a half second it took them
to put that thing on um
when we when we hit 900 000 on youtube
we were scheduled to hit a million on
january 9th
okay thanks to you guys by yesterday it
had been moved up to january 6th
oh my goodness we are now in 2020 so
thanks to people subscribing
the target the estimate for a million
has now
been pulled just barely into this
calendar year 1231 2020 is now the
projection
for a million subscribers so we now are
only we've made 10 days of progress
in the last three if you understand what
i'm saying
meaning if we can keep this pace up it
is conceivable that we could hit a
million subscribers by election day and
if that happens
we're i'm going to destroy all of my
equipment in celebration it's going to
be crazy i'm getting i'm going to get
all new equipment after destroying
it's going to be like a rock show so
very very exciting but in all
seriousness if you are watching on
youtube
consider hitting that that subscribe
button because it really does do a lot
for us
thank you to yanthalala for gifting
10 oh god that's going to be clipped 10
community subscriptions over on youtube
we have already completed the second
level of a hype train
which is just crazy let's see what is dr
redfield doing by the way a lot of it's
reported by
by teachers we've seen that go down
we've seen emergency cases and
emergencies kind of holding it up to his
face that's interesting um okay
super chats are coming in let's see here
uh kyle says it's ascii
not asc2 i prefer to say asc2 much like
i call it tulsa oklahoma
tequin sends a super chat user says if
you want to understand trump you need to
know about the dunning-kruger effect
yeah i've actually interviewed david
dunning check out if you want to
understand trump
check out my interview with david
dunning emmanuel kant says have you seen
the new lincoln project ad wake up
yes it's very good daniel huberman says
is it fair for republicans to blame the
virus uptick on protests
well listen it depends which protest if
there were maskless protests then
certainly
most of the george floyd protests were
with mask
with mask protests uh yeah it looked
like redfield
was it was almost like he was
chloroforming himself with that mask i
recently
read a book um oh it's called uh the
poisoner's handbook
and it's about the the sort of start of
um uh the science of determining whether
people have been poisoned super
interesting book and yeah he
did look like he was chloroforming
himself there let me say
thank you to natasha deboer
who is new member number one today at
joinedpakman.com
christian koch is new member number two
couch is number two johan erickson i
think europe is heavily heavily
represented today because the time of
the stream
johann erickson is new member number
three and ajamu
omowale is new member number four great
to see you ajamu
i really appreciate your continued
support
we are um just four percent from
achieving
a level five hype train over on twitch
which is
very very exciting we are um
waiting now for the start of this press
briefing with kaylee mcinanny
um scheduled for the bottom of the hour
doctor check out fauci's mask
technique he knows to go right for the
ear
what would you call them the ear um
restraints the ear straps
and look at look at this strategy watch
him do it if and when he does it here
oh now he's folding up the mask it's a
little too much touching of the mask i
would say he's really
all over the mask but his technique the
ear containment straps the flappers
maybe
yeah his mask technique is absolutely
perfect thanks to bill w for gifting
five subscriptions
over on twitch and getting us to um
to a level five hype train simrick says
the fouchy mask maneuver yeah that's
what i would call it i think that that's
actually a perfect way to describe it
adrianne says dukakis was polling the
same way in 1988.
yeah listen let's not become complacent
at all
about the polling it just you know
bidens up biden's down
uh just everybody's everybody has to
vote there's no i know it's become meme
that i say everybody has to vote none of
this means anything but
you can find polls from this point with
hillary trump where hillary was winning
by double digits
they were less common dukakis there's
all of these different examples so yeah
there
anybody becoming complacent is um
risking being devastated on november 4th
and i don't
want to see that nerd alert says
good morning from las vegas it's burning
with vid
don't forget to hit the like button yeah
khaled hawaz lee says hey david i'm a
paid subscriber to you on youtube
do you prefer i subscribe on any other
channel or site happy to help
listen the best place to subscribe is my
website because
all of these other platforms they're
taking
slices to quote uh andrew yang it's like
everybody wants a slice
a slice a slice we control the full
process on our website and we just pay
to um swipe credit cards essentially so
joinpakman.com is the place and i will
i'll just get my my membership mention
out of the way right now
the best place to support us is
joinpakman.com the daily hour show
the 20 minute bonus show the one two or
sometimes three streams a day
all of this stuff is funded by website
memberships a lot of people have had to
cancel in the last month or two
because of coved coronavirus 19
trump cov20 whatever you call it in your
home
you know what i'm talking about uh the
trump flu
etc um so everybody that signs up at
joinedpakman.com is sort of alleviating
that uh
crisis that a lot of people are
experiencing i believe the normal prices
are
beautiful prices perfect prices but i'm
glad for you to take 66
off by using that coupon code 2020 now
66
off and unpublished coupon code ends
today
this is a july only coupon code
completely unpublished
july surprise okay july surprise
all one word all lowercase it's the last
day of july
expires tonight at midnight midnight
eastern or midnight pacific
it's a good question in any case july
surprise
is an extra coupon code and that's
something very very important to keep in
mind
still standing by for kaylee mcinanny so
we'll keep an eye on
what's happening um at the house of
representatives
hearing room here mr biscuit says i
guess we're only progressive so long as
the sitting president isn't dictatorial
then we abandon prince abandoned
principal
and settle for moderate conservatism
i i don't totally know what you're
saying but i'm pretty sure i disagree
with your perspective
uh respectfully of course we've achieved
a full and complete level 5 hype train
on twitch we are at 112 remember that
the record
is 620 percent level 5. we are at 112
there um let's see other messages coming
in
mike oxhard says have you put on the
quarantine 15 there's a before and after
photo of you circulating on twitter
and your face has filled out since 2019.
no i've i'm actually i've lost weight
during quarantine shockingly i think
it's probably because
i'm i'm eating out less and uh
i would love to can somebody i would
love to see that can anybody tell me how
to find
a supposed before and after picture of
me on twitter
that sounds absolutely hilarious yeah my
zooks and cukes if you eat enough ten
inch zooks
i guess potentially you might put weight
on um
yeah if anybody can tell me how to find
this uh before
and after picture that sounds hilarious
oh man nobody can help me okay
david is thinner now people are pointing
out wow
my biking is definitely incremented
here come the photoshops yes by the way
if you
if you want to make i have a i'm worried
that i'm opening up a can of worms
but if you have uh supposed david fat
memes that you want to send me
i would love for you to send them to me
david davidpakman.com
and uh i always am glad to display memes
from the audience if people
send them all right so nobody can tell
me where to find these before or after
oh man make maggi nanny great again yeah
all right well i don't know if somebody
can superset it
i will find it i i'm scared of what i
might see
okay um d ken
uh i can't stand the liar dr fauci i
think his earlier lies about wearing a
mask
is a bigger deal than the press is
making it out to be i can't stand the
liar dr fauci oh my god
that's not good five two one
says where did that go you the man
i can only watch these things with your
commentary thank you
bjorn eric knutson says my student fee
for following dps class 109
nokia dollars no i know that's norwegian
kroner
um this is weird that the video has is
anybody live in the room with the
magananny press briefing does anybody
know
we don't know okay i would love to see
how close we are to this fiasco
people are getting triggered by the
masks going on enough you know what
really bothers me
when i'll be in the supermarket and
people are just like
constantly fingering the mask like they
constantly have to touch it and i'm not
talking about
sometimes when you talk i get that it
gets pulled down and then you have to
pull it back up
but just people who can't keep their
hands off of the mask it's like just
just leave the mask
wait until you get out of of you know
the supermarket
and then pull it down
c-span is a feat of the entrance okay
let me see that i mean i would take the
entrance to be quite frankly
to be quite frank with you uh
c-span
let's see what we have happening on
c-span here
i can't even find the live feed on
c-span to be totally honest
yeah i don't know
yeah it's just not i mean i i love when
people are at
so much of the chat is just commenting
on how i don't know what i'm doing and
it's like listen guys i
understand what's going on uh it has not
gone live yet i will refresh
the fox news one nope still not live
okay we're just keeping an eye on it
i will go volume up on white house feed
just so we do get that eventually
emily maiden says is it possible to sign
up on your website if we're already
youtube members yes these are two
completely separate and unrelated things
they have nothing to do with each other
thanks to eric roth's child for the
three months of support on twitch with
the message jersey
okay few other website members i want to
thank
dan stone is new member number five
today
stephen whiteside's row is new member
number six
nicholas kelleher is new member number
seven
janie stewart you are new member number
eight yumi
charbonneau is new member number nine
we're getting into dicey pronunciation
territory
andrew kalin wait did i thank andrew
already
no andrew is new member number 10. anne
malmsten
is new member number 11. david fray
is new member number 12.
lily rundlet is new member number 13.
hayden sandford is number 14.
brian barrons is number 15
and peter banks is number 16 today
i'm doing what i can to keep up with
these i think i'm mostly caught up
uh but i may have missed a couple and i
will get back to them very soon
let's listen in briefly to dr fauci
salons i haven't seen one hair stylist
oh no it's just
goes out and attacks police or set
something on fire but we've seen all
kinds of that stuff during protest
and we know the protest actually
increased the spread of the virus you've
said that
i said crowds i didn't say specifically
i didn't say
protest to anything so the protests
don't increase the spread of the virus i
didn't say that you're putting words in
my mouth no
i want i would i just want an answer to
the question do the protest increase the
spread of the virus
imagine being so backwards as a country
that fouchy is the enemy
are known particularly when you don't
have a mask
to increase the acquisition and
transmission
no matter what you don't have a position
on whether the protest
increase the spread of the virus or
don't increase the spread of the virus
i'm saying that crowds wherever the
crowds are
can give you an increased probability
that there's going to be acquisition
and transmission but do you understand
americans concern
protesting according to particularly
according to democrats is just fine but
you can't go to work you can't go to
school
it's just about masks my friend you're
an idiot all three of those
fundamental activities first amendment
activities but protesting's just fine
you know jim the gentleman's time has
expired but i'll just
ask the gentleman to just think about
his question
and put it in reference to crowds that
gather
in political at political meetings
at fundraisers without masks on an
oil rig in texas nobody wearing a mask
nobody social discipline but a
fundraiser right
would that be problematic
with that i'd yield five minutes to mr
foster
we we are really an embarrassment of a
country guys i mean
you know other countries i just was by
the way by the way i was recently
interviewed on a new zealand program
by uh it called department of
conversation with pat
britton and it's publishing on my
channel soon it's already on his channel
and we were talking about how uh in new
zealand with jacinda ardern
it's not like she's doing crazy things
she's just recognizing she's a
politician she's not a doctor
get doctors and public health people to
tell us what to do and
here they've weaponized opposition to
medical experts
look at tucker carlson look at
janine pirro laura ingraham
um you know jim shorts jordan all the
congressman kovid louis gomer to all
these different people
the world is horrified by what we're
doing here where dr
fauci now is a political figure you know
it's it's an embarrassment and you know
getting rid of it
would start with getting rid of donald
trump
but it would certainly not end there and
it is a real
complete and total embarrassment uh if
you're just joining us you've not
missed uh kaylie's press briefing yet
they called it very suddenly
for a much earlier time of day than they
are typically scheduled for
and they're running late as usual i'm
going to take a look
at whether it has been rescheduled if
the white house
calendar has changed at all um
nope still scheduled for 10 30 and trump
has a meeting at 11
30 that will have press so you think
they have to do it soon because
otherwise they're going to just run up
against that next event
so we'll keep an eye on it and see
what's going on thanks to boys
for subscribing with twitch prime
dashboard has subscribed on twitch
rewoundvhs has also subscribed on twitch
if you are watching on youtube you can
get a message up on the screen in the
lower left by using the super chat
function carl smith for example says
trump likes to refer to negative polls
as suppression polls
wouldn't positive polls be better at
suppressing votes by complacency
generally speaking yes i agree in fact
i've said that the the risk of so many
negative polls for trump
is that it actually um uh mobilizes
and activates his supporters to say oh
he might lose i've got to go and vote so
it's
not only is it indefensible empirically
it's also
obviously counterproductive it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever
neptune says enjoyed the only fans post
today david thanks oh yeah you should
see what's on my only fans it's really
crazy
uh no of course i am not actually on
only fans i am on
cameo and in fact i think i have a bunch
of cameo requests i have to do
i have four cameos i have to record
maybe i'll record them after this i
am on cameo i am not on only fans there
is no private only fans
or or anything like it um
donna williams says have you considered
staying on for a few minutes after
kaylee is
for further discussion enjoying your
commentary yeah i might stick around a
little bit today depending on how soon
they start i do have a really really big
day today my uh
car lease ends in mere hours i've got to
fully clean out my car
and uh get ready to return it and um
i've gotta
weed my um my my cukes and
zuks and there's just a lot going on
today
uh my inbox has absolutely burst with
emails so it's i've got a bunch of stuff
to do but if they get started
relatively soon i i could maybe stick
around a little bit after
let's see here tara banesh says just
home from the hospital this is a good
distraction to heart problem sorry to
hear that tara
don't don't like to hear that anybody in
the audience even congressman kovitt i
don't wish uh
the virus upon him or anybody
let's see here uh people asking why
lease versus own
uh i don't know that we have time for
that right now but
in short when i uh owned vehicles
i tended to um
replace them every three or four years
anyway
and for me leasing particularly when
it's done through
my business it's completely deductible
it's like renting a car
whereas if you buy a vehicle you're
subject to certain deduction limits
i also have the advantage of knowing i'm
not going to have
any repair fees of any kind because the
vehicles are relatively new
um and i like trying out different types
of cars i'm going electric next and i
think that's going to be very very
exciting and i'll report to you how that
is going uh once i get into it still no
live video from kaylee mckenna nanny
um we'll see what's going on who knows
you know they abruptly call a press
briefing
much earlier than they normally do it
and then
they're 15 minutes late and we still
don't even have live video in the room
it doesn't make any sense it's very very
strange
michael blanco says remember when the
wright called biden a conspiracy
theorist when he floated the idea trump
would delay the election it's crickets
now yeah in fact i
have been posting about that to my
twitter um
and it's uh peeps at least someone owes
biden an apology
keith stone says my girlfriend wants
fauci to do the fmm on her oh boy
that's not appropriate for this stream
that's for a different stream
patrick miller says nancy pelosi is hot
brandy buck says easily the most
professional political channel thank you
patrick miller do you have a discord
server yes i am not at all involved in
it there is an unofficial david pakman
show discord
and it i have nothing to do with it but
we do have there is an
unofficial discord server there's a lot
of activity on it in fact
and you can um find it on discord
let's see other super chats
adam bennett says what are you looking
down at when someone signs up
down i'm not i'm looking over when
someone signs up i look over
at one of my five monitors so for
example
steve schwartz just became new member
number 17 and it's over on another
monitor
ryan usselman is number eight oh
i see what you're saying i'm looking
down at my keyboard so i can type in the
right numbers
to update this bar that's what i'm
looking down at
lars winther number 19
darren armstrong number 20
debbie hilton number 21.
james coquiat number 22
garrett bloom is number 23.
um selena weber did i thank selena i
think that okay let's call that 24.
selena might have been counted twice who
knows also thanks to eddie g
for the twitch sub saying ireland viewer
here seeing american politicians attack
scientists
isn't something i was expecting to see
in the 21st century you and me both
also [ __ ] smash has subscribed and says
keep up the good work david thank you i
appreciate that
um you've not missed anything i know a
lot of people are wondering if it's 10
48
is the briefing over no it's not we're
not even in the pre-briefing phase yet
it's really weird uh thanks to heather
and rob for subscribing on youtube
robin neal says dave you're awesome what
do you think about pompeo's comments
about barr making a decision about
moving the election
completely dystopian and horrifying i
mean really just absolutely horrible
and uh we have to hope that that's just
not true
um it should not be up to william barr
to decide if we have an election that
would be crazy i'm told that now this
news has
live video from the press briefing room
so let's take a look at that
we may have to sit through a brief ad
here but i'm told that this is live live
live let's take a look
uh back it up here
very long ad here okay live
it actually looks like it's getting very
close the room is actually quite full
already
for whatever reason fox is not live and
neither is the white house but we'll
keep it here for now it seems like it's
uh it seems like we're getting close
okay essential says answer to jim
whatever the contact
tracing shows yeah dr fauci could have
gone in that direction
gary thompson says hi david perhaps the
orange man will spend the weekend in his
white house bunker
checking the rum reservoir and stocks of
plasma
best wishes from the uk yeah uh if
you're just joining us yesterday donald
trump
pronounced plasma as plasma
multiple times and i was just laughing
all night
all night i was laughing because of
plasma and
rim disavar rim disavar i was thinking
like there has to be something wrong
with him right like imagine that for
example
um you know like on the show a word that
maybe is not the most common word but
that comes up often because of what i do
would be um what's a good example i had
an example this morning that i was
thinking of like on the show i regularly
use the word
uh man now i'm forgetting of the i had
just a great
example what's a word i use on the
program regularly that maybe is not
such a common word in in general
conversation that would be a good
example
no not tool c not tool c uh
[Music]
everybody's saying tulsi no no no um
you know how about like politicization
okay that's a word that maybe like if
you know accountants probably don't use
the word politicization
etc imagine if for months i was saying
it
and after saying it i was like you know
there's a lot of politicization in the
united states
wouldn't that be weird if after that
long i was still having trouble saying
the word like it we would start to
wonder whether there's some problem that
i have when it comes to
speaking or or something like that like
trump's been saying you know
redesigner is something that's been in
the lexicon for months at this point
and like he still can't say it
convalescent plasma has been in the
lexicon for months at this point
in time and he's talking about plasma
and
part of what it might be is that nobody
afterwards wants to be the person who
goes up and says listen mr president
it's plasma and especially the longer it
goes it's like when you forget someone's
name
and then you're like oh i don't want to
ask them for their name and then you see
them a third fourth fifth sixth time and
you realize
if now i ask them for their name it's
gonna be really embarrassing because now
we're on like the tenth time that i've
seen this person
it could be the same thing where nobody
wants to go up to trump now and say
sir sir routine it's not plasma
it's plasma because he will lose their
mind
he will he will lose his mind on them
rather people asking about
bt tv emotes over on twitch as far as i
know
i enabled a bunch of them yesterday but
you know it's like i've added the bt tv
thing to chrome
i've added it to firefox i hit add emote
on like 10 or 20 different emotes
i don't know what else i can do oh
what's going on sounds like we have live
video somewhere oh good we have the live
feed over on the white house now that's
good we'll stay here
i prefer this feed perfectly frankly
um okay very good anyway
you guys tell me if some of these uh
emotes are enabled i enabled a whole
bunch of them
and i don't know what's going on all
right
we have achieved ten thousand live
viewers over on youtube which is very
exciting
jim jordan pedo enabler says peasant
media
luis lopez says good morning from sunny
san diego david pakman show greatest
real news outlet standing strong
deserves more than a million subscribers
when can we buy apparel
we had to completely shut we had to shut
down all apparel sales
because i was basically you know how
trump early in the virus said
the us government is not a shipping
clerk i was becoming a shipping clerk
because production and shipping were
taking so long because of the virus
that every day i was fielding five to
ten inquiries about where's my stuff and
it's like i'm trying to stream
i'm trying to uh you know record my show
i ca
i actually can't be a shipping clerk so
i had to shut down
all apparel sales for the foreseeable
future and obviously i would love to
start it back up once
um once things normalize but i have no
estimate at this point in time
josh sitter konishi says
well where'd that go josh sitter canisi
we in canada don't blame americans for
your president
but if reelected then the blame is on
all americans love your streams yeah i
mean if after all this we don't remove
trump
it you know we deserve we deserve some
kind of punishment
osborne says david don't you like
eggplant i lived
off eggplant one summer but i still like
them yeah i didn't plant any eggplant
this year
um partially it was because by the time
i went
that was weird what was that okay i'm
gonna mute this
we don't want multiple audio streams by
the time i had to finalize what i was
planting
none of the stores i went to had
eggplant seedlings and it was too late
to plant seeds
um okay thanks to
liam hamama for subscribing on twitch
with the message i wish someone asked
trump to define per capita in a press
conference i
i tweeted that two months ago it would
be great for trump to be asked that
question
eddie g oh no i already read eddie g's
message good
we're actually caught up there good a
serious scaper
says just became a member on the david
pakman show website happy to support you
thank you i appreciate that
a few other people i want to say thanks
to teresa gegen
is new member number 25. roger ricker
is new member number 26 laurie martin
is new member number 27 and todd mobley
is number 28.
let's see what's happening today hello
everyone good morning everyone uh we're
going to begin with some brief remarks
from chief of staff
mark meadows and he'll be giving you all
an update on phase four negotiations
oh my god it's really bad already
uh good morning as you know over the
last uh several days we've been having
conversations on capitol hill secretary
mnuchin and myself with
democrat and republican leaders both in
the house
and the senate last night
we concluded a meeting with senator
schumer and
speaker pelosi a little bit before 10
o'clock
and uh at the president's direction
we have made no less than four different
offers
to uh democrats on capitol hill i think
it's no fewer right
and make sure that the enhanced
unemployment
that is set to expire today along with
uh eviction protection that is set to
expire
as well is protected and those four
different offers
have been uh actually
rejected but more importantly than that
uh
they've not even been countered with a
proposal so the democrats
are certainly uh willing today
to allow some of the uh
american citizens who are struggling the
most under this
uh pandemic to go unprotected
and the president has been very clear
for us to be
aggressive and forward-leaning to make
sure that they get protected
and yet what we're seeing is politics as
usual
from democrats up on capitol hill uh
it surprises me like attacking a doctor
who's just trying to save people yeah
passion and caring about those that that
truly
are in need that a temporary
solution to make sure that unemployment
enhanced unemployment continues
has been rejected not once but multiple
times
the democrats believe that they have
all the cards on their side and they're
willing to play those cards
at the expense of those that are hurting
oh my god
we'll continue on with additional
discussions today with
senator schumer and senator uh and
speaker pelosi
uh perhaps an in-person meeting tomorrow
on capitol hill
because we stay engaged but i'm
i'm disappointed in uh
what we've what we've experienced over
the last three days and i want to stress
there's essentially nothing here that's
newsworthy there's no actual substance
here
whatsoever that would be like if i were
to report on what he said i'd have
nothing to say
uh the president has sent us back not
once not twice but three different times
to try to find some common ground and
what we found from
our democrat negotiators is that they
are bumping the price
higher than the very bill he they
continue to talk about the left
democrats playing politics and they keep
using this pejorative the democrat party
the democrat leaders like right oh
you're not playing politics right mark
rose bill they have a hundred billion
dollars
for schools we
matched that offer and actually put
forth a proposal for 105 billion
dollars for schools for k-12 and higher
institutions and yet what did they say
to that
oh no that was two months ago we want to
increase
the the the amount of money that we send
to schools to 400 billion dollars
okay we're going in the wrong direction
they're going in the wrong direction
because of partisan politics it is very
disappointing
and uh so we call on capitol hill
to uh get serious about their
negotiations
the president is serious about the
negotiations we're willing to engage
as you know uh leader mcconnell
yesterday put forth a one-week extension
at the current levels for enhanced
unemployment and what did we see
senator schumer objected to that so
there's no clear message
that the american people should receive
other than the fact that the democrats
are willing to pay play politics at a
critical time right that's the best
nation's um very dire circumstances as
we deal with this pandemic so
i wanted to give you that brief update
so that you can have it uh
straight from uh there's nothing to
report on there it's just meaningless
dribble
uh over the last three days and uh as we
work i'm gonna i'm gonna turn it over
to uh to the the press
uh secretary and i think she forgot her
name didn't he
liability insurance is that a red line
for you guys mcconnell said it was
thank you guys i think she'll address
that the
um i'll take your questions in just a
moment the chief has to run to a meeting
but earlier this week i just wanted to
start off with an overview of what we've
been doing on kovid the president
rather president trump visited the great
state of north carolina to highlight the
important work being done as part of
operation warp speed and thanks to
president trump's leadership
the trump administration has made
substantial investments
including investing in multiple vaccine
candidates with several
entering phase three clinical trials
including astrazeneca
moderna and pfizer providing financial
infrastructure for mass manufacturing of
potential vaccines guaranteeing doses of
a vaccine will be available for
distribution
shortly after approval the race for a
coronavirus vaccine is truly moving
at warp speed under president trump in
addition president trump is leading on
therapeutics over 140 clinical trials
are now underway
trump has done nothing as far as that
goes under trump has nothing to do with
it
in monoclonal antibody treatments
yesterday president trump visited the
american red cross headquarters to hold
a round table on donating plasma
this initiative will empower americans
to help their fellow americans
in battling the virus these critical
investments in a coronavirus vaccine are
due to the fact that we have a
businessman in the white house and
according to the wall street journal
quote democrats blame the us case surge
on inadequate testing and contact
tracing but the u.s has averaged two to
three times
more tests per capita than most european
and asian countries indeed we've done
more than 59
million tests uh with india at number
two
uh with just about 14 million tests
remember that once you get into the
second phase of the disease
the countries that are worst off are the
ones that need to keep testing so at
this point that's not even the relevant
story
in south korea have averaged the us is
the undisputed world
leader in testing um and on top of the
more than
59 million tests that we've done the fda
has authorized more than 193 tests under
emergency use authorizations
including molecular and antibody tests
under the leadership of president trump
the us is leading the world and safe and
effective therapeutics and the rapid
development
of a potential vaccine together as one
american people
we will defeat the invisible enemy and
with that i will take questions
oh god paula thank you on mark's mark's
comments about how it's democrats who
won't compromise democrats came up with
a plan two months ago the republican
plan was just presented on monday and in
that time the president has contradicted
the republican plan on the amount of
stimulus checks on student loans
mitch mcconnell threw you guys under the
bus on funding for the fbi building what
do you say to the tens of millions of
people who are going to lose their
benefits when it appears that the real
issue
is that republicans cannot agree among
themselves even though they have months
that's not it at all in fact um
democrats offered a three trillion
dollar
plan uh we have a very specific focus
right now
um and it's not this comprehensive plan
whether it be the heroes actually oh
democrats are doing that
that narrow focus is this that americans
are about to lose their unemployment
insurance
and this white house this chief of staff
this president this secretary of the
treasury
have all remember that for for months
republicans have been trying to cut
unemployment in order to force
businesses to open
now they're saying that's their focus i
mean it's all it's it's
crazy as mark meadows uh just said to
you uh and
how many proposals have the democrats
made zero and
if you want to know where the democrats
um true intentions lie look no further
than the martha mcsally bill
look no further than two months ago they
already had a proposal out employment
insurance
it was rejected by chuck schumer and
that was a plan that the president was
willing to endorse white house
what do you say to those that are going
to lose 600 a week in
unemployment uh payments that need that
money
and also uh why didn't you start
negotiating earlier and why only the
offer of an extension of one week that's
cure phillips right i've met her before
this is unacceptable that the democrats
have been fundamentally unserious and
uh the you just heard the chief of staff
say a great example of that is they had
this massive three trillion dollar bill
that called for
a hundred billion in school funding we
then gave 105 billion which then was
deemed insufficient so if democrats were
interested
in extending unemployment insurance and
helping the american people
they would have endorsed the martha
mcsally bill and extended
martha mcsally's a complete nut and her
bill was crazy democrats had a bill two
months ago i mean it's just you can't
unless you want to argue that time
doesn't move forward you just have to
concede that six hundred dollars a week
that they need to be calling the offices
of chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi and say get to work um
and stop engaging in politics
of hard-working americans who deserve
these checks who lost their jobs through
no fault of their own are you willing to
pass on the liability protection
um that's a that's a question for mitch
mcconnell he said that that's going to
be a part of any bill
but that's mitch mcconnell's uh that's
his priority
liability protection for businesses so
they can open without i mean
we'll talk about that after it's crazy
that's our focus time yes
kaylee if the president is so worried
about how long it'll take to count
ballots in the election then why isn't
the president and this white house doing
everything it can to secure
more funding beautiful for staffing
yes and other resources to make sure
that we can have a safe and proper
election
look what this white house is focused on
um is making sure
he definitely has a page for that not
riddled with voting fraud and that the
timetable is not
hung up here um we are there are several
lawsuits that the campaign is engaged on
and i would point you to the campaign
for specifics
answer my question though my question is
what is the white house doing to get
more resources for funding and staff to
make sure
the president says that it will be a
secure and safe election well as you
know peter
states run their elections um and it is
if that's the case then they decide
whether to delay and trump shouldn't
even be talking about it
is ensuring that what jeffrey toobin has
said over at the new yorker cnn
contributor notably
new york's primary vote count chaos
signals trouble
for november and as he noted you want to
talk about the president but jeffrey
tuban himself
democrats control the state government
of new york they are responsible
for creating the fiasco that is
unfolding now and that is certain to get
worse in november states need to get
their acts together
um when it comes to uh elections and as
we see in new york
is it up to the states or is it not up
to the states to decide
to have the election national race and
that is certainly not what we want to
see
i'm asking you about the president you
said you asked why i was asking about
the president i'm asking about the
president because you work for the
president i guess the question is
oh wait a specific oan oh my god so the
president's meeting this morning on a
few minutes with the national
association of police organizations
um in 2008 2012 they supported barack
obama and joe biden
in 2016 they didn't support either
candidate and now in 2020 they're
endorsing
president trump uh to what does the
white house attribute this change
well it's clearly how is that even a
journalistic question
look at the polling on defunding the
police abc
news ipsis poll 64 percent oppose
defunding the police huffington post 57
percent oppose
rasmussen 59 opposed but make no
mistakes democrats
want to defund our law and law
enforcement it comes at a time where 64
of americans say they are concerned that
growing criticism of america's police
will leave it almost seems coordinated
like the oan
kaley stuff community where they live uh
the
american people have seen very clearly
where the democrat party of today stands
it's at an unacceptable place
and i think that um this administration
has shown thanks everybody i'll leave
you to think about that
um who every day are out there defending
and protecting
our streets and democrat-run cities that
have turned um
abundantly cities in general are run by
democrats like because
democrats tend to live in cities darlene
can you explain why the white house did
not
uh counter with a comprehensive plan of
its own you said
the white house was focused on two
things the unemployment insurance and
addictions
why not why not have a more
comprehensive proposal to counter what
the democrats have put on this so i've
walked through at this podium uh the
more comprehensive plan that this white
house
uh was hoping to see in our priorities
like tax rebates
unemployment benefits enhanced hiring
and retention payroll credits workplace
tax credits
restaurant donations and others those
are all part of the the heals act so
there is a comprehensive plan that was
put forward by republicans on the hill
with several white house priorities in
it but
right now at this day at this moment our
focus is making sure that americans who
have lost their jobs get their paychecks
it's why
as you heard the chief of staff say
we've made four proposals
democrats have made precisely zero jack
what's the nomination of general tuttle
is the white house still behind that
uh the president still uh supports
general tata yeah
kaylee so is there anything that that
you agree with on the democrats after
all these negotiations are there any
points of unity so far
well look they've prov they've presented
zero plans so we've presented four
they've presented zero so
do we democrats have been saying we need
a second stimulus for months and they've
put out a plan
it's it's fantasy world stuff to say
well
in the last 48 hours they've not given
us a plan
they the republicans have been saying we
don't need a second stimulus for months
now
mcsally's bill to ensure uh that that
those who are receiving those checks
continue receiving
them upper limit haley for the amount
that you're willing to go to is the
white house decided on some sort of a
cap for how much you're willing to spend
this round
not that i'm aware of the president i
has said you know he wants to make sure
money gets to the american people
the trump administration wants 377
million dollars in the chronovirus
relief bill for
the um the long delayed modernization
of the west wing how is that a priority
in terms of the coronavirus pandemic
you guys talked about priorities you had
the fbi bill which
doesn't seem to have much support from
capitol hill as well so uh two things
and i'm glad you asked that because i i
do want to um
give you some details about those two
items in particular um when it comes to
the fbi building this has been a long
discussed
issue um i would note that the three
previous covid bills that have been
passed had plenty of other things in
them that were not related to covid one
of those examples is the
harbor maintenance trust fund this is
not a red line for us
it was a part of the initial bill but it
is certainly not a red line the priority
as i've said
several times so far is unemployment
insurance
making sure americans do not get evicted
and then with
as it pertains to white house
renovations um many of those
pertain to safety protocols filtration
systems
enhance community communication ability
um and needs that we saw that were
highlighted
right so everything that seems
extraneous that republicans want is
crucial
anything that actually is related that
democrats want is extraneous
got it get their checks that is the
priority
i'm ensuring that americans do not get
evicted that is our
number one number two goals thank you
kaylee i just wanted to confirm reports
that mark meadows actually made an offer
to extend
unemployment insurance by four months i
have not i've haven't spoken to him on
that precise uh proposal but as he's
mentioned there were four that were made
maybe a follow-up question then i want
to change gears and talk to about
twitter
we reported yesterday that the israeli
government wrote to twitter's ceo
asking him to remove tweets from iran's
supreme leader
ayatollah khamenei calling for the
genocide of the israeli people
uh the company refused to do that
because they said that the tweets will
quote
comments on current affairs i'm
wondering uh if the white house has a
response
given that twitter has recently begun
restricting
the president's own tweets for
glorifying violence
glorifying violence and spreading
misinformation and if you have spoken to
the president about
any further action perhaps he's taking
on social media companies
yeah it's a great question ebony i did
see that new york post story
and i thought it was very eye-opening
and it tells you where the social media
company stands where they're not
willing to uh to to assess the ayatollah
khomeini's tweets
but they are willing to assess president
trump's tweets it's really
appalling and it just speaks to their
overwhelming blinding
bias um against conservatives and
against this president
um and we are taking action the
administration i mean what's crazy is
the ayatollah is extremely right-wing i
mean it's like how can you how can you
say
that there's anything left-wing about
you know that form of government and
actual theocracy
it's that this is wild to escape civil
lawsuits for their own speech fact
checks and d
platforming and the petition seeks to
expose social media companies
to liability as a speaker or a publisher
if they act as editors of content on
their platforms or remove lawful speech
based on politics and very good work by
the new york post
and highlighting that issue yes thanks
can i follow up on darlene's question on
tada for a minute you said that the
administration is still behind him but
is you guys considering putting him in
an acting role i have no personnel
announcements other to say than the
president still supports him
thank you it's been a month since the
reports of
russian bounties on american military
forces and yet
the white house has done nothing to push
back on putin
what is the what what is the delay
trump's enamored with putin that's all
answered
probably a dozen times from this podium
that intelligence um is unverified there
are dissenting opinions on the
media is i would point to the department
of defense saying there's no
corroborating evidence to validate
recent allegations and i see allegations
in recent press articles have not been
verified
or substantiated by the intelligence
community and odni has a similar
statement
but look this president acts he is not
afraid
to stand up to russia he's done so
repeatedly when our adversaries
have to write this is not any kind of
conspiracy it's just trump's enamored
with authoritarians
and putin's at the top of the list and
trump's just enamored with him he's not
going to criticize him he's not going to
go after him confront him
retaliatory defensive strike um he has
continually stood up to russia will
continue to do so
and this president uh will always
protect our troops and our men and women
overseas
i mean he will act on verified
intelligence
thank you ma'am um so colorado hawaii
oregon utah and washington all have
automatic
mail-in ballot systems the white house
has made its position clear on absentee
ballots and also the concern
over these universal systems
does the white house think that those
elections are fraudulent or more at risk
abroad always a mail and ballot system
mass mail out ballots
are going to be more at risk of fraud
look at la county where
it's harder to suppress mail-in ballots
when you can't send armed
paramilitaries or people saying you're
going to need an id even when you're not
or whatever the case may be it's tougher
to intimidate people in mail-in voting
that are that are not accurate ballots
that were mailed out
this is a very basic concept and it's
one that the media has done a very good
job reporting on
not just jeffrey tubin at the new yorker
you also had the washington post article
on this that the president held up
yesterday
that says the results um that they that
they've seen
in a study of showed that there's an
unexpected stress test of male balloting
systems many of which were designed to
handle only a small portion of the vote
and are not ready to scale up in
response to a pandemic that was
washington post
there was another great um abc piece
mail they're arguing
we're not ready for the number of
mail-in ballots that we're expecting
and we're gonna make sure to make it
even harder to get them sent around
by closing post offices not allowing
overtime hours for usps workers etc
they're like here's a problem
which we are making worse so we
shouldn't do this thing mass mail and
voting
uh certainly subject to fraud um and
good work on the part of abc cbs
washington post and the new yorker for
highlighting uh the fraud that is at
play the delays that are at play
uh because those are after all the facts
another quick one uh
the chief sounded quite frustrated a
second ago is there
any situation in which the white house
will walk away from negotiations on
phase four
i won't get in the middle of the
negotiations and i'll i'll leave that um
to the chief
and to the secretary of treasury um but
yeah there's a there's a lot of passion
because
we're passionate about making sure
americans are taken care of i've heard
the president personally talk about this
the only priority is getting trump
re-elected uh that those who have lost
their job get these payments
um and those who through no fault of
their own um do not get evicted from
their homes so those again
two big priorities for the president um
raquel
yes thank you so much i have two
questions one
you were here saying that uh how well
the administration is doing is
responding to different things but the
facts
don't show that and americans are
struggling and scared
how do you what do you tell them the
american people
so the one thing i would say is um the
president's made clear that we're at a
place um where
we want all americans to make sure that
they socially distance
um and that they make sure they engage
in mitigation tactics
um and uh the president's been been
clear on that
um but you know one of the things i
think as when you look at the united
states response you look at
the fact that we were supposed to have a
ventilator shortage in fact we had a
ventilator
oh my god we were we were told that
there's a testing shortage well it turns
out we've done at this point almost 60
million tests uh this president led on
the
development of ramdesevere we just saw
this week promising signs from
convalescent plasma
our therapeutics are advanced um i would
argue the best in the world
um and that's why when you look at in
particular at the case fatality rate
um which the president often talks about
um
i hope you guys realize that these are
all all these are like
unjoint disjointed total number of tests
case fatality rate this is this is not
like a systemic
uh sequential way of actually analyzing
what's going on
um and it's patriotic as the president
said to wear a mask
especially when you can't socially
distance hunter
hunter i'm a travel base yes there is a
movement drawing called
love is not tourism they they are
families and couples separate for a
month
because of the travel ban couples who
couldn't be together
on their child birth or mothers
themselves or separated during
illness they are asking if the
administration could consider
a waiver in their cases um i haven't
spoken to the president about those
specific cases
but this president will always put
america first this president
put in place the travel bans to protect
american lives and they've done that dr
fauci acknowledging that
the travel bans have saved american
lives and that that is our goal at this
moment hunter
thank you kaylee uh two quick questions
for you um herman cain passed away
yesterday and obviously he had tested
positive for covid
nine days after attending the
president's rally in tulsa officials
there have connected the rally to a
spike in cases
is there any concern that herman cain
may have contracted
coronavirus at the president's rally and
is the task force doing any follow-up to
track other potential cases from that
event
well herman cain is the absolute
embodiment of the american dream
we are grieved and we are very saddened
by his passing he was raised in atlanta
georgia on a small farm he left with
just the clothes on his back
we're not acting for his bio i mean he
rose to be an extremely successful
businessman and someone who was
um who contended for the nomination of
our party um
and i i would refer you to a post on
herman cain's website
and he says i realize uh or his website
rather i realize people will speculate
about the tulsa rally but herman did a
lot of traveling the past week
i don't think there's any way to trace
this to one specific contact that caused
the infection
we'll never know um so that and i will
not politicize
um herman cain's passing and i would
just note the great contributions he's
made to our society will always remember
him and his legacy will stand then just
follow up on another point um obviously
the president's tweet um yesterday
seemed to float the idea of delaying the
election
he later said you know he supports no
date change whatsoever
given a little bit of the ambiguity and
confusion there can you just say
unequivocally whether or not the white
house
wants to see the date changed and state
100
that that is not something that you
support the president answered this
three times
yesterday he said i want the date more
than anyone i don't want to delay i want
to have the election and then a
local interview he did he said no one
wants the date of the election more than
me
because he believes november 3rd will be
a moment where the american people
um acknowledge the great successes of
this administration
yes okay thank you does the president
support the chinese-backed hong kong
government
in delaying their elections yeah so i do
have an answer
for you on the hong kong elections um we
condemn the hong kong government's
decision to postpone for one year its
legislative council elections and to
disqualify
opposition candidates this action
undermines the democratic processes and
freedoms that have
underpin hong kong's prosperity and this
is only the most recent and a growing
list of broken
promises by beijing which promised
autonomy and freedoms to the hong kong
people
until 2047 and the sino-british joint
declaration
uh i think it's appropriate as we see
this play out on the hill this is her
because she's gonna this is her walk off
right now by our doctors to just ignore
scripted walk off
real successes um and and work of this
administration i acknowledge the
ventilators
um and i talked about testing and just
great american industry coming together
the american people coming together
and working to get us through in
conclusion pandemic
um and we we grieve when even one life
is lost
but i do want to point out just the
early actions of this administration
when there were zero reported cases in
the united states on january
6th the cdc issued wuhan travel notice
before
any u.s confirmed cases um but what were
pelosi and chuck schumer doing they were
calling on the gop to support
this is literal trash there are reported
cases in the united states on january
17th the cdc
implements public health entry
screenings at three major u.s
airports receiving the greatest volume
of wuhan passengers
what were democrats doing oh house
democrats were preparing to file their
first brief and the impeachment
sham impeachment inquiry when there was
one reported case
in the united states on january 21st cdc
activated emergency operations center
what were democrats doing oh chuck
schumer was calling for witnesses in the
impeachment trial and pelosi released a
statement
criticizing mitch mcconnell for his
trial rules and
finally when there were seven reported
cases in the united states on january
31st president trump issued travel
restrictions on china
and the first mandatory quarantine was
more than 50
years and those travel restrictions
saved american
lives but what were democrats doing
pelosi was introducing the no ban act
which would have imposed
undue limitations on the president's
authority to restrict entry of aliens
into the united states and what are
chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi doing now stopping
americans from getting their
unemployment insurance
and it's despicable and it's time for
them to come to the negotiating table
thank you very much needs better acting
lessons i think
oh my goodness it is it's like does do
does she think anybody's going to report
on that i mean i guess i should i should
ask the question
do her what does the content of her walk
off ever actually
become newsworthy in any way i mean it's
just like at a certain point she turns
to a random unrelated page in her
notebook
reads a bunch of crap and and then walks
off it's not uh
there's nothing there's no there there
there's nothing there essentially
um let's just listen to a little bit of
what's going on with dr fauci here
wearing a mask is the critical issue
right
i agree with that and i um think that um
i will go to restaurants to allow me to
sit outdoors right
and not in those are me too i've been
following the science and i've been
agreeing with all three of you as to how
we are
yeah no re i've been walking by some uh
cafes recently
and there's people sitting inside like
nothing's going on and i get that
they're limiting the number of people
and you've got to sort of sit apart but
it's hot right now like what's the
reason why i don't need to go sit inside
i do think that the outdoor dining is
reasonable right now and i did it when i
was
on vacation and and so on and so forth
but
sitting indoors right now when we're
starting to see even the states that are
handling the virus well
see an uptick because you know
eventually it's just bursting at the
seams
it really doesn't make uh any sense to
me before you head out if you join me on
youtube
all 12 000 of you please hit that
subscribe button on the way out
subscribing is completely free we're
trying to get to a million subscribers
by election day right now
we're targeting we're uh projected to
reach it on december 31st so with just
a little bit of tweaking that curve we
want to do the opposite of flatten the
curve we want to lift the curve
um we could get there by election day so
if you have no clue who i am and you
just
ended up here because of the um youtube
algorithm
please hit that subscribe button on the
way out
targeting 1 million if you've been
watching on twitch
likewise we are hoping to get to 50 000
followers on twitch very very soon i'll
have an announcement about my
forthcoming stream
with grand master hikaru nakamura very
very soon and i'm looking forward to
you joining me for that uh and i will
talk to everybody very very soon
you